there's really nothing you can do to
please these climate change Fanatics who
swear the planet's on its deathbed a
group of Eco Warriors in England who
call themselves The Tire extinguishers
which is pretty good slashing the tires
of some dudes eco-friendly Tesla and
then leaving a leaflet on the windshield
which states your gas guzzler kills the
group behind the sabotage is defending
its action saying quote electric cars
are fair game we can't Electrify our way
out of the climate crisis so judge if we
can't Electrify our way out of it where
are we supposed to go how are we
supposed to go around well I want to
know how many trees they had to cut to
put that note on everybody's windshield
you know they're destroying the trees
you know they're all crazy they really
are they you know they should get a get
involved in something that where they
understand what's going on I do agree
with them on the batteries electric
batteries are a problem for the
environment big problem Jessica big
problem I'm just yearning for a good
protest like something that makes sense
yeah mag rally Jess I'll be there Iowa
I'm I'm thinking about coming when I'm
out there okay Trump um I did not expect
the tire slashing for the Teslas yes I
why not just Embrace if if you want
something to change you could have an
incremental change and go for electric
cars if that's really going to be the
future but wait until they hear about
the wind turbines did you know Jesse
that each wind turbine requires 80
gallons of oil for lubrication once a
year and I'm not talking vegetable oil
this is like the real so there's nothing
basically they just want to in
the this isn't an energy issue it's not
even a political issue it it's a
psychological issue you're look if you
look at the typical activists that are
blocking the roads for example the young
ones do it for obvious reasons they've
yet to invest in life so they don't
understand the cost of their actions to
others they don't have famili spouses a
job so they don't understand the damage
that they're doing to people who are
already trying to live a hard life then
you have the older protesters that have
failed in life and therefore they find
satisfaction in other people's pain if
they aren't happy neither can you that's
why they're out there that's why it
doesn't matter if they're right or H
wrong or hypocritical so this is what
happens we have nothing going in life
you slash A stranger's tires and this
goes to the overall lie that undermines
all of this activism that they're caring
that they're virtuous that they love
others it's the opposite this is born
from an insecure ego that drives them to
harm people and create chaos because
they have nothing in their life worth
protecting there's nothing in their life
you can harm so they take it out this is
all a product of Envy there's this is
why those protests you see with they
they block the they block the bridges
today they block the the tunnels people
are trying to go to work on a Monday
they don't care because they hate
themselves and they project the hate
onto you don't don't even think about
the fuel don't even think about solar
doesn't mean crap to them yeah I talked
to a lot of these activists about their
personal lives in my new book right get
it together and you're right Greg it's
all driven by insecurity yeah much like
glad you brought that up get it together
now available for pre-order hi everyone
I'm Brian kilme I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now